during the course of the campaign what  was the music it was a tiny dancer Billy  Joel uptown girl  why why these white I need a Backstreet  Boys but it wasn't Backstreet Boys at  the end of his Backstreet Boys okay why  was it he liked these he liked these  songs we would ask why are you playing  the same songs on loop Nessun Dorma  Pavarotti on on loop over and over again  for 510 days at 95 to 100 decibels just  over and over and I was told that Donald  Trump played like those songs right so  where did he loves the Backstreet Boys  it just seems so strange I that was a  late comer to the campaign thank God  because I don't know if I would have  made it otherwise and let me I don't  want to alienate anyone I think they're  a terrific group but I wish them all the  success in the world those kids are  going places  you